Welcome back everyone this is good to be my
peacemaker trailer video.
They just released a brand-new teaser trailer
for the john cena peacemaker series it's going
to be the HBO spinoff series from the suicide
squad movie that we just got done watching,
so there's a bunch of Easter eggs here.
Obviously a lot of funny moments because that's
kind of how peacemaker rolls in the DC universe.
But if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
I will be doing episode videos for just like
I do for the marvel Disney plus series it's
DC's first real big HBO series that they're
doing that's a spinoff from the movies.
They're doing that with a bunch of the movies
now the other big one that I'll also explain
after I talk about the peacemaker trailer
footage is the Batman spinoff series that
they're doing for Colin Farrell's Penguin
character.
That's right we have two Batman spinoff series
that are coming to HBO from Robert Pattinson's Batman Movie
But careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the suicide squad movie.
Because will be talking about everything that
happened at the end of that the post credit scene
because that's meant to set up the peacemaker
series and give you an idea for what the timelines
going to be so in the suicide squad movie
post credit scene they reveal the john cena's
peacemaker character survived his big gunslinger
standoff moment with bloodsport at the end
of the movie where it seem like he turned
on the team because he was on a secret mission
within a mission for Amanda Waller to prevent
any evidence that would implicate the US government
in a negative light.
With respect what was going on with starro
in Corto Maltese so inside the Oppenheim Bay
civil wasn't clear peter Capaldi's thinker
character explains that he was actually an
employee of the US government the US military
experimenting on starro in mind control trying
to find a way to weaponized mind control for
the US government, so the unofficial secret
of the suicide squad movie is that the actual
villain is the US government and Amanda Waller
also kind of the film of the movie, but because
peacemaker has such a hard on for justice
and lady liberty America as he says that he's
doing everything he can to bring peace to America
Even if he has to kill every last man, woman
and child to get it.
So he was reluctant to kill Rick Flagg is
like please don't make me do this, but he
does it anyway.
So just winds up being a bigger douchebag
a bigger dirt bag by the end of the film the
way James Gunn explained it is that Rick Flagg
and even bloodsport character have the sort
of hero arc where they become better characters
over the course the felt like they start out
being kind of despicable characters like you
would expect antiheroes in the DC universe
people that would be on the suicide squad
by the end of the film they wind up having
this big heroes journey with a become even
better as people rest peacemaker has sort
of opposite arc during the film.
Like he starts out being kind of a despicable
character, but becomes even worse by the end
turning on the rest of the team clearly choosing
the darker path, but in the post credit scene
Emilia Harcourt and Steve Agee's John Economos
most's are being forced by Amanda Waller to
be peacemakers handlers during his new mission
as he starts working for Amanda Waller on
separate black ops missions and as they complain
like they're being forced to do this because it's retaliation
Punishment for the team knocking out Amanda
Waller which he tried to activate all the
suicide squad members bombs.
Even though these two characters were not
the ones that actually knocked her out there
couple other funny details that didn't really
come across in the movie.
James Gunn explained about Amanda Waller's
back story.
He said the reason why Rick Flagg got put
on the bad suicide squad team was because
at some point in the recent past Rick Flagg
had made fun of one of Amanda Waller's outfits
in the office.
Like they been just walking around the prison
on one of their normal days and he just laughed
at her for whatever outfit she was wearing
and that's the reason why Amanda Waller basically
sentence him to die putting them on this bad
team.
Just to give you an idea for how much of a
grudge Amanda Waller will hold against people
like oh you made fun of my outfit okay time
to die.
Note to self do not make fun of Amanda Waller's
outfits, but when they're walking into the
hospital to inspect him to see what how he's
doing.
He recovers in the hospital for a little while
longer.
There's a small time jump then that's when
the events of the peacemaker series are going
to pick up if it wasn't clear there are going
to be eight episodes of peacemaker the be around
like 40-45 minutes long obviously in this trailer
footage you see Emilia Harcourt and Steve
Agee's John Economo's characters coming back
the other confirm big comic book characters
that we see in the trailer here are vigilante
played by Freddie stroma he's a new version
of the character.
They did a version of vigilante on arrow in
the later seasons.
So obviously he's got a look way more hard-core
than the arrow version these two characters
sitting next to peacemaker here in this booth.
While they're having their little meeting
is Leon autobio and Clemson murder there his
other team members working under Amanda Waller
Argus.
But the trailer footage starts with him putting
a record on in the morning.
Like in his tidy why he's just rocking out
as you do when you're peacemaker the logo
on his record cartridge here that the camera
focuses on is just a standard audio technique
a cartridge even though the triangle scene
reminiscent of the Argus logo triangle, but
he seemed crank of the dial on his retro sound
system.
Like Marty McFly at the beginning of back
in future cranking the dials up as if this
is the way he wakes up every morning.
Just rocking out to his tunes in his underpants.
This is obviously meant to be very reminiscent
of the suicide squad movie when there in Corto
Maltese deep undercover in the jungle.
Like they were still trying to be super stealth
at this point.
The beginning of the film.
He took off all of his peacemaker gear.
The whole suit pants and all while he was
sleeping in his tidy why these they played
for big  moment with in a big moment.
Because the reveal happened while they were
freaking out about king shark trying to eat
rat catcher to it to me the funniest part
of all this other than the huge oversize ultra
muscled up john cena looking completely ridiculous
in tidy widest to begin with.
The funnier part was that he didn't react
to bloodsport reacting to his current state
of undress as if he didn't even consider that
the other members of the group might think
it was weird for him to be walking around
in the jungle on a hardcore black ops mission
with a group of trained killers in nothing
but his tidy why use it even though purchasing
his living room here we actually got a look
at the outside of his house.
This is what it looks like it's a mobile home
that he just converted into a more permanent
structure but is painted red white and blue
because of course he would do that even is
old muscle car is also painted with the American
flag.
Like the do she is version of Captain America.
You could imagine event.
I think john cena described his character
that way when they were first promoting the
suicide squad movie a couple years ago.
Like think of him as the do she version of
Captain America.
Don't worry, I will talk about the muscle
car in a second, because is pretty hilarious
with American flag and his pet bald Eagle
that he has in the backseat here.
The zoom and enhance around his living room
here you can see the decor makes it look like
his sense for aesthetics, design, fashion
just style in general is all frozen in the
1970s and 1980s.
He does kind of feel like a crazier version
of a classic 1980s action hero like imagine
a crazier deranged version of Arnold Schwarzenegger.
But inside the living room, there aren't any
particularly huge DC Easter eggs in frame here
Just a lot of trash lying around and super
old the core.
I'm sure once they release more trailer footage
we get a look at the episodes the be some
bigger DC Easter eggs around the other parts
of his house.
I'm expecting them to release that bigger
trailer at DC Fandome and then we'll talk
more about what's actually going on with the
series because you don't really get a sense
for the story during this early teaser trailer
here.
But James Gunn said the story gets way more
crazy in sci-fi than you're expecting.
But the next couple of scenes here with the
meeting seems like is all part of the same
seem like him getting out of his car and then
going to a meeting with the rest of his team
from Belle Reve prison Argus all them working
for Amanda Waller on these new missions, so
this talk about the car here obviously.
There's been a lot of jokes made about this
old time he muscle car.
So if you couldn't tell it's a 1970s Mercury
Comet and James Gunn himself in the comments
here called it a shifty car like one of the
worst muscle cars of all time.
Like I said peacemaker is supposed to be a
really suss kind of character everything about
him screams douchebag the just something not
right about him up top you notice the license
plates are Washington plates.
Because that's where he lives.
But even funnier joke here the plates read
pissmaker as if his name is pissmaker instead of peacemaker
I'm sure they'll be a couple jokes about that
during the episodes.
But Emilia Harcourt calls about for wearing
his full peacemaker costume with his gun in
his holster in broad daylight.
But the trying to keep a low profile in his
costume is the opposite of that, then the
next scene, seems very familiar its him having
another shootout competition with vigilante
the new character.
You can only see part of his costume here,
but is meant to parallel the same shooting
competition that he had with bloodsport in
the suicide squad movie as you can see he
just tries to play up his superiority to vigilante
during this competition by making all kinds
of funny trick shots and then shooting the
peace sign into the block here to represent
his name peacemaker the other comic book characters
that they confirmed our version of judo master
Robert Patrick is going to be playing peacemaker's
father is named Auggie Smith.
I'm sure he's going to be crazy Amanda Waller
briefly referenced his father when they were
introducing him during the suicide squad movie
will probably find out about more the comic
book characters coming to the series when
we get to DC Fandome next month in a bigger trailer
But if you spotted any other big Easter eggs
in this trailer that I didn't talk about during
the video just right them blown the comments.
Like I said, I will do a bigger trailer video
when DC Fandome gets here.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any those videos
and my full marvel what if episode 7 video
will post Wednesday just like normal everyone
click here for my brand-new eternals trailer
video for kit harington's black knight and
Richard Madden's Ikaris character and click
here for my shang chi movie post credit scene video
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you next video!